so breaking news out of afghanistan
again where the taliban has captured the
northern provincial capital of
kunduz in another significant defeat for
the taliban
taliban for the government i should say
the taliban fighters attacked early on
sunday morning and captured the city
battling street by street during hours
of intense fighting
officials and residents in kunduz are
describing
total chaos so in just three days this
is what's happened the regions we've
marked in red their provincial capitals
have fallen to the taliban zarage in
nimrod's province
kunduz which you've just been hearing
about the government hasn't officially
confirmed this but sources tell us the
cities have been lost
and those two regions in grey only the
taliban is claiming to have taken
those provincial capitals that's
sherbargan in jazan province
and now we're hearing about sarah paul
as well in the
next province across charlotte bella
sent kabul to take us
through the charlotte i said it
yesterday i think it bears repeating
the speed with which this is happening
now kundas
is quite astonishing
it's happening incredibly quickly i
talked to the taliban
even a few weeks ago and they were
surprised themselves at how quickly they
were gaining territory
it really is taking everyone by surprise
about how quickly
these provinces are falling so if i
start with kunduz this is incredibly
significant we talked to a local
journalist who confirmed to us
that kunluz has fallen that there are
taliban in the police compound and the
intelligence compound and the governor's
compound
and the election commission's office
they've taken the prison they've
released prisoners
and that they're flying the taliban flag
in the centre of the city
the government earlier denied that
condors had fallen to the taliban but
the ministry of defence
has just uh put out a statement saying
that they are launching
a clearing operation of the taliban in
the city
to try to push them out fighting has
been ongoing
around the outskirts of condors in
recent weeks but it was this morning
where the taliban pushed into the heart
of the city
they came from multiple directions and
managed to take it
quite swiftly now kunduz is significant
because
of its location it is on the main
highway between if
you're trying to go from north eastern
afghanistan into kabul
you have to go through kunduz and if the
taliban have condors that essentially
cuts off north
eastern afghanistan from kabul it's also
the bread basket
of afghanistan in about 2015 2016
it actually fell to the taliban and it's
the only city to have fallen to the
taliban in the last 20 years if you take
the last week out of the equation
and then it only came back into
government hands because u.s special
forces were deployed
and they managed to get the taliban out
but now
uh u.s special forces aren't on the
ground anymore of course
okay thanks for those updates charlotte
bellis in
kabul also in kabul now abdullah bahir a
lecturer of transitional justice at the
american
university in kabul i don't know if we
would say transitional yet but
something's happening isn't it and the
as we were saying with charlotte there
the speed with which it's happening
is extraordinary but i also wonder
we knew the us and nato were leaving
something like this was always going to
happen
so i guess a very important aspect is
not to hit the panic button too early um
most of the crises that the world has
seen
is people freaking out before the fire
has
actually started um the idea is yes
these are
concerning developments but this is a
tale
a story that has happened before back in
2001 the taliban did hold all of this
territory
and now it's a much more trained
upon forces with uh aerial backing from
the united states uh so there is hope
it's just that
uh right now it's just taking time for
the government to adjust they have never
been um under such an offensive before
um so it only makes sense for them to
lose certain territory only to try and
get it back
so let's just see now what the
government's reaction is going to be to
restore an equilibrium
so you don't think then this is going to
be like a
you know a series of dominoes that keep
falling i i just as i say
you know four potentially four
provincial capitals
in three days does kind of feel like a
panic situation
um yeah so the idea is that
even when you panic sometimes you have
to not show your panic especially not to
the enemy
uh the idea is that um
there has been a significant change as
well with regards to the united states
involvement with
with b52 bombers involved in
two of these provincial capitals um
the idea is urban warfare is going to be
a bit messy it's not going to be as
clear-cut to take back these territories
um but um there there's hope that i
guess the
government just needs a shakeup with
regards to the realities on the ground
and
once a proper military strategy is put
into place
they can start pushing outwards they
have the better equipment they have the
larger
forces they have the better aerial
dominance or the the only
side that has aerial dominance in the
fighting
so hoping this just doesn't replicate
throughout afghanistan
please realize that the afghan defense
forces are overstretched as well there's
a lot of territory that they cannot have
all their troops stationed at at all
times so
um i guess now when they plan as to how
to take these territories back we'll
have to see what
uh the afghan defense forces are capable
of okay
are there other particular places in
afghanistan right now which you think
are particularly vulnerable
the idea is the the
trend of the fighting is going to change
with the changing weather
most of the fighting the taliban have
made
it a point to attack areas that they
previously were not
that strung in 20 years ago so
they tried to clear up the north to a
great extent i think they will start
pushing towards the south
more and more with regards to cities
like
jalalabad are going to be really
important because then that cuts off the
whole south
if that city falls helman is already
facing
very tough fighting and the idea is
these are major cities i guess
keeping hirat out of the taliban's hands
was a major win
but the smaller cities even if they
might not mean much
symbolically they matter the fact that
it makes a headline that four
provincial capitals have fallen in four
days is uh
problematic it hits the morale and
conviction level of the
forces so um let's hope that they start
changing their fortunes uh
sooner before more and more territory
falls abu dhabi is from the
american university in kabul thank you
so much for your time